police in London say they suspect
terrorism after a man crashed his car
outside the houses of parliament the car
hit some pedestrians they ran into and
then it ran into a security barrier this
morning two people were injured now this
happened a few hundred yards from the
scene of a deadly terrorist attack
nearly 18 months ago Debora patta is on
the scene with the latest Deborah good
morning good morning here at Westminster
the area is in lockdown police have
cordoned off all roads around the houses
of parliament in what is being treated
as a terrorist attack it took just
minutes for London police to arrive on
the scene guns drawn they surrounded the
car arrest of the driver and led him
away in handcuffs security cameras
captured the moment the car hit a group
of cyclists before ramming into a
security barrier one bystander said he
saw one of the cyclists get up and
attempt to chase the car ambulance
services treats at least two people on
the scene before taking them to hospital
but no life-threatening injuries were
reported
Scotland Yard says no one else was in
the car and the suspect is not
cooperating with the investigation
now Parliament is in recess here so most
lawmakers were not at work today
normally this area would have been a lot
busier during rush hour traffic when the
incident occurred
fionna good to know that no one was
seriously injured Debora patta in London
thank you